hi slugs so today's episode is my
favorite that i think we've done in a
really long time because we got to know
each other
just it was good i don't know what to do
we didn't see each other inside each
other i feel like when you say that
people think it's going to be sexual but
it's actually so much more than that
yeah don't you agree like i totally
agree we just got we got into it i feel
like kalylah finally like
let us know that what her name who she
is
finally let us be her friends i'm like
so grateful right now you guys i and
annie i and annie i annie we do stand-up
comedy and we're gonna tell you where
we're gonna be so in may this coming
month soon i'm gonna be in minneapolis
and in chicago and denver and you can
get tickets at esteronice.com and i
think sleepover might finally be back
check out sleepoverbyester.com to see if
there's a new drop if not there'll be
one soon all right what's up sluggies i
am so excited to be on the road i've
been having the most fun with you the
this stand-up is fun but the meet and
greets are insane i love when you guys
come take pictures with me i will be in
san jose california i will be in dania
beach florida
i will be in omaha nebraska then in june
i will be in st louis missouri houston
texas burbank california west nyack
austin texas just go to annie
letterman.com shows it's unbelievable to
meet you i can't wait to see you guys if
you've already been please come again
i love you
by the way
taking off the toupee from the
livestream
yeah is that why you really did it it's
like you gave me this that's crazy why
did you no i wanted well that's a fun
bonus i really honestly did not know
that would happen but it was two hours i
was trying to give you it's like getting
a pet
yeah or a turtle that lasts lives longer
than you and you can't touch it if you
touch it you could die you have to set a
savings account aside to take care of it
when you're dead
you leave it to your you just have kids
just so they can take care of your
um turtle okay wait so his two okay
i wanted it to get cut like i wanted you
to have like a fly haircut i didn't know
it was gonna be placed to top your head
like
awesome the fact that she put glue on
your existing little baby i thought she
was gonna shave it down
and i could kind of see from a distance
but i didn't want to like alert you and
scare you because i didn't want you to
back out of it
but in my mind
and i wanted you to see what happened no
i was never gonna back out of that but
it definitely hurts so much taking it
off with even
waxed your head because i called him
that night i was like just so you know
when you take that wig off like i know
you like your baby hairs so like there's
an oil to try to did it work or no like
um
like 85 work do you have to use acetone
i used what the
lady gave me the adhesive oh tell tell
them about you went to
oh yeah and i like left my adhesive here
and i was all the way in burbank and so
i went to some salon and it was all old
ladies and i was like hey this is a
toupee
they're like no [ __ ]
they're like you say a toupee
[Laughter]
they were redirecting me to sally beauty
which i guess is a big chain to find
what are they like all of you
know what sally beauty supply is i
didn't know what it was you're not gay
this is your this is your coming out
you're straight that i'm straight thank
you
like you just heard of it for the first
time that's like kind of cool though
that i don't know what sally beauty is
no i don't being gay or straight is not
cool neither is uncool or cool
i just you want me to be honest
we've been we want to know what you are
i've told you for years 10 years i'm
straight
okay so what are the rumors circulating
it's confirmed now because of the
sally's what are the rumors circulating
about um carlos ester
one rumor is that he and you have like a
a side thing going on sexually like i
have
male friends
in my bed all the time but it's just
it's it
i don't know it's i just don't see it as
any different if it's like truly there's
no sexual no this is this is my family
carlos could literally like i give him
permission those are your feminist
platforms
literally
um like when he was adjusting my vagina
for the live show
like i feel
so comfortable doing that but what can
we break down why is it because you know
you're not going to [ __ ] he's been
here no he's not going to try to [ __ ]
you yeah because you're
he's an old
he's you know he's been eating out my
[ __ ] for the last two years oh god so
you know it's more than a comfortable
thing for me he's been bobby standing
you know what i was thinking about
similar height
similar height very different body shape
okay so i got a massage when i was in uh
arizona i went to sedona a couple weeks
ago for a little spiritual journey if
this doesn't end with you getting
molested i don't want i didn't get
molested but i wanted to i wanted to to
ask you guys if you have this feeling
too
where i'm sure there will be a new
molestation at some point
i'm sick of like getting mining these
old molestations
i know there's hundreds of them
we need new new molesteds no
todd will defend me i know but let's
let's really bait them this stuff
we can't ask for we need new stories
but okay wait so all right so i'm
getting this massage and
um my
one of my like mentors lives out there
and he was like you should get a massage
from this guy and he was of course so my
mentor is gay so it was like the hottest
guy
and he was like no no he's really good
i'm like okay really is he a good mr
like he was so he ended up being a great
massage therapist i'll i forgot his
[ __ ] name i'll say it on instagram
but um
super good looking guy and i was like
gonna shave my legs before just to not
be embarrassed but i do that when i get
pedicures too i always wanna like i
don't wanna but then i realize that's
actually
giving in to some sort of thing where
i'm trying to seem attractive or perfect
to other people who are not in my life
sexually but i was going to say do you
feel like if you go get a massage or
like even like i've been going to the
egg doctor and i'm like
i kind of don't want to shave my [ __ ]
before i go like i don't want there to
be any i don't want to like look good
there well can i say something crazy i
learned on tick tock this week yeah
that women shaving their legs and
underarms was invented because
razor companies wanted to sell to women
like it's all it was like a money scheme
like it's no it's just it's nothing yeah
it's so hard to un program that in your
head like that to me is really hard
because when i do see a woman it might
be hard for you it's been really it's
been very hard for me with you
when we were at whitney's over the
pandemic esther took her pants off
and it was i mean this was was this the
first time we were meeting olivia
oh maybe it was i think it was like it
was like we're going to leave and then
it was like olivia munn's coming over
but we could hang out a little bit
longer and at that point you weren't
thinking oh dear god i have to find a
razor no esther's esther i don't give a
[ __ ] i really respect that about you
yeah i it just
yeah i wish i had like a story behind it
it's just i just don't shave often she
has i know what you mean though annie
because i before i got here i was a
dermatologist yeah i know i was just
gonna say your skin looks really [ __ ]
good that's not what he said i have a
really bad um eczema outbreak on my um
on my chest
thank you milk
thank you milk um but um
you know i also have a couple dry
patches on my torso on my body and one
in between my ass crack that's just an
eczema patch wow i've only seen that
part wet i can't imagine that being dry
glazed that's how i really see it yeah
it's like a delicious doughnut like a uh
a nice half milliliter doughnut
and um i felt the same i that thought
did cross my mind like should i you know
appear a certain way yeah you know and
he was a male dermadol but it's like
sick it's like why am i thinking this
yeah and you're literally molested by a
doctor it's like it's crazy it's like
what is like what is in our heads that
just keeps going and
i did usually i go really [ __ ] up
looking to the doctor i actually kind of
looked okay and i'm like oh my god i did
this i did it again what do guys expect
from us like what do you want from us it
reminds me of like when i was in
in middle school and high school when
you were had two options of either being
a [ __ ] tease or a [ __ ] there was no
other [ __ ] option what were you
esther
uh
absolutely neither but you know for them
to ask her to be there
too short for anyone to notice i was
there
um yeah no i had one boyfriend in high
school though and yeah yeah
i had a boyfriend in high school break
through my window my my the head of the
bed was um to my window and i used to
live by marshall high school in pasadena
and he played for the baseball team in
marshall high school and i guess i fell
asleep and i didn't pick up the phone
the night before so he broke through my
window and he like from the window
because my head my head was through the
window he like punched me awake
wait what yeah sorry we just punched me
how old were you uh 16.
your high school what high school
boyfriend he was a tooth fairy
he was trying to grab some teeth he was
trying to get some teeth
he broke the window who paid for no no
no my window
he didn't smash through the window it my
window was where i would go in and out
of the house he smashed you know through
her
work so he opened the window he pried
the window open it was one of those
things that would swing open my head was
through the window and i was probably
like so good
and he was like you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then he punched me straight down and i
was like anything that happens when
you're asleep because i've had a
boyfriend who used to wake me up
screaming at me while i was like dead
asleep that i didn't suck his dick
enough literally my tmj would be i'm
like i'm grinding my teeth because my
tmj is so tight from sucking your dick
so much
like a violent like obviously being
punched is different but like
being screamed at you like you [ __ ]
i'm like being strong you're in a
[ __ ] dream you're like floating
you're doing something cool maybe you're
naked at school worst case scenario
my sister dated a guy once where he
needed to have and he needed to
drain his balls every night that was his
thing
why unless you say it that way
i don't know how else to say it yeah
cause it is like it's like he had to
extract the poison yeah extract the
poison yeah so when she wouldn't when
she would deny him the drainage
he would be
my sister would be like he would just
sit in a dark corner in the bedroom and
start ripping pillowcases yes and
yeah the feathers kind of just do this
in the dark and she was like he was so
[ __ ] what are you like [ __ ] the
thing that's what it was like the
feathers were just going but that's the
thing just like get a pocket [ __ ] or
something it's like you can only do
because i was like i was in the spin of
the toxicity of this relationship too
like i was like okay i'll obey you i
guess but i could only do so much you
could like it was crazy like i would
[ __ ] him like three times a day oh my
god
and then he like i would suck his dick
sometimes but it was hard to suck i have
[ __ ] a medical condition did you guys
get those doctors no it was honestly
i mean i should have slept i [ __ ]
should have i should have the doctor
call in the middle of the night like i
know that i paid him like it's happening
again
honestly sex every day is boring it's
just not it's boring but here's the
thing and we did have good sex and stuff
but it wasn't enough for him because he
was quenching some sort of thirst that
would never be quenched because he's
sick and even good sex every day
eventually just becomes born can i tell
you okay so i don't know if i should
even i don't like i do want to keep
things private but also it's like todd
and i have this conversation we're in
the wrong profession i think this is
good for people i mean i have no privacy
i've never kept a secret
i can keep other people's secrets which
is so weird that's my codependency i
actually in the same way like when it
comes to me though i will just spill it
but i know it's hard because it's like
whatever yeah
you don't even shave your [ __ ]
esther was wearing it was a long sleeve
shirt
a
the swimsuit was like long on the top
and then it looked like it was long in
the bottom and then you realized it was
just a bikini bottom but her [ __ ] hair
was so long it looked like board shorts
look if you're going to have this thick
luscious hair on top it's going to
transfer over to all parts and that's
why i have clip-ins all over my [ __ ]
that's that's that's actually untrue
because a lot of asian women have very
beautiful like thick hair but they're
hairless in the legs most of the time so
sorry about that i'm so cocky about it
too
of course wait what we were just talking
about when i interrupted myself oh okay
so todd
okay so todd and i i was like we gotta
[ __ ] cause we hadn't [ __ ] in a while i
was like we gotta [ __ ] or whatever and
we were like making out and stuff and
then like i was trying to
we gotta [ __ ]
i was trying
i was just getting like really i started
to just get in my head about like how i
hadn't [ __ ] him in a while and i was
like getting like so upset with myself
and i was like you know i'm just like
damaged and all this stuff and todd was
like
there's todd was like there's nothing
wrong with you he's like any and then he
was like he's like anyone he's like
we're normal we decide what's normal we
decide what's healthy it's not what
other people do and it was just so god
said this yes todd is a king he is the
number one and his ego is not attached
into like getting [ __ ] like you know so
many guys like they need to get your
[ __ ] it's not even about [ __ ] you or
like being with you or having that
connection it's like getting your [ __ ]
let me have that or whatever and it's
not all guys it's just a certain type of
guy but todd's like we live in this like
industry with these [ __ ] guys that
just wanna [ __ ] everyone like they're
sick those are the people that are like
they can't keep their dick in their
pants they have to [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] they
never feel good there's never enough
he's like those people are the unhealthy
people we're not the unhealthy people i
like i love what he said like you guys
decide what's right for you and i
like as someone who's been in a
relationship with the same person for
almost 10 years like i am so over the
friends i have who are like we've we
have sex four times a week i'm like
that's a lot you're lying or you've been
together for less than a year like
or you're they have another thing
they're having an upset they also might
have that might be they might have
matching um love languages which are
physical touch like it just like depends
like it's just my intimacy like todd and
i are very cuddly and stuff like that
and we still [ __ ] but it's just like not
it's not the number one yeah
sex life can look any way you want it to
look right because uh i think the
unhealthiest sex life i ever had was
something similar to annie's where i
felt obligated to have sex with my
partner every night for four years and
one could say oh we [ __ ] every day i
mean that sentence alone would make
another person feel like oh i'm
inadequate i'm not [ __ ] every day but
if she were to ask more i'd be like i
hate it actually yeah i'm not happy
great you know this is not you know what
i want i just feel like somehow things
are not going to be good in our
relationship if you know we don't
partake in that
every night you know i know and it's so
weird because you do have like you like
i think dr drew said that where it's
like you get like almost like sexually
bipolar where it's like sometimes you're
on sometimes you're off but i realize
like
how much is that i'm trying to like
reevaluate how much of all this has
always been about like looking good to
men pleasing men
some sort of like reliving this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i went through over and over again
and it is like it's hard to sift through
that and now that i'm in like a healthy
relationship it's so nice to not have to
like there's no pressure put on me and
that sucks because i know there's a lot
of people who
the men are just like really hypersexual
and the women just can't like keep up
like it sucks and that's something you
have to work out or whatever but it's
just right and i know sometimes you
sometimes you gotta just
it's it's weird it's weird to be with
someone for a very very long time and
expect to feel that just magnetism to
them right like i mean even for bobby
like i know when he first met me like we
were very sexual with one another we
would have sex with everybody
multiple times a day we were very
attracted to each other it was very
animalistic but as the years went on you
know he became very deeply addicted to
porn and i felt then very like
secondary to that porn because that's
eventually what he preferred because
number one it was convenient it was fast
and it was something that he could do
alone without engaging without the the
the work of having to engage with a
partner right and he'll talk about this
openly where
even in the last three years of our
relationship like that's been such a
sore point for us the fact that i almost
convinced myself that maybe i could be
in our relationship without sex at all
because i was like okay let's maybe what
i'm feeling is that maybe i've become
asexual or maybe i don't need sex or
maybe
because something unhealthy was
happening in our relationship and i just
felt
how do i say um
like i just felt that
like completely physically useless yeah
i stopped doing my nails doing my hair
looking pretty wore sweatpants all day
and i almost de-sexualized myself
because i didn't want to be hurt
like it hurt me so much that he had
chosen this all
alternate option for sexual release
right and um
you know eventually we got to it wasn't
until
last year where everything sort of came
to head and
you know he said something to me that
i never felt was there was nothing i
could have heard that was more
earth-shattering to me which is it would
bring me relief if you had sex with
someone else
like it verbatim out of his mouth and he
said this in therapy
it would and this is not bobby speaking
this is addict bobby's right this is
someone addicted to porn this is someone
addicted on you know who had committed
to relapsing on drugs this is somebody
for three years has been a dry drunk
and i felt very like sexually neglected
and he straight up looked me in the face
and said it would bring me relief if you
had sex with someone else
and i remember crying for a whole week i
remember just being like i don't know
like
i i think that my [ __ ] left my body in
that moment like i was like well
well let's just i think there's a lot of
people out there with catcher's mitts on
[Applause]
so it's like you know and and then when
people view us they think oh they're in
a you know perfect decade-long
relationship and this is what i'm here
to tell you guys is that sex is a very
very complicated layered thing i'm
somebody who's sexually abused bobby's
someone who's sexually abused maybe we
were like sort of ambivalent and dancing
around this this idea of both being sort
of sexually broken people coming into
this union together and trying to
sort of think that we're supposed to be
this healthy uniform but it's not that
simple you know and finally we're at a
place now where we can like tackle it
head-on and we can do it in an honest
that's so funny i imagine you guys [ __ ]
like sumo wrestlers like you literally
tackle each other
um but it's still such
a big barrier for us because we've been
so
almost like
we're intimate like in the sense that we
hug we kiss we do all that but it's such
a big barrier for us and it's been years
since we've truly sort of
like
been
or felt super sexual towards jesus
towards each other but it doesn't mean
our relationship is is is is not working
our sexual relationship is not working
well it's just things you have to keep
checking up on too because it's like
everyone like changes and evolves but
it's like when you can't be honest with
each other or like how that must have
felt for you when he said like that it
would be a relief for him or you're like
what now like
my natural like the things that i need
in life are like a burden on you or
whatever is what i would get that's how
i would have thought i also go back to
what todd said it's like we are making
this up as we go there's no just because
like
the people who came before us did it one
way doesn't mean that that's the right
way or there's no there is no right way
like you're right and here's what i
really
like
grinds my gears a little bit is when
people think that very traditional
old-school possessive monogamy is the
way
to do it and those are the people who
have not been in long-term relationships
those are the people who have who are
very closed off to the idea that you
know what
whatever happens between two people is
the agreement between those two people
and i don't know why i want to sit on it
does that make me molested i want to put
that inside me
a little bit but do you know what i mean
i know exactly but also those people if
it works for you it doesn't mean it
works for everyone else it's so weird
that there's like and i think these
these things all came out to try to like
help people with their sex life
like well you know like to have a good
relationship you need to have like a
healthy sex life or whatever but then it
puts things into both people's minds
where it's like men are looking i'm
assuming that the men is it's not always
the case that the man is the one that's
more sexual than the woman ever
obviously but it's like you know it just
puts in people's heads that there's
supposed to be a certain amount of
there's this thing outside of what your
relationship is that you're supposed to
be aiming for and you're not like
communicating with the person or i just
don't like that feeling of like secret
because i think i have so much shame
around sex that it's like i'll like
sneak masturbate and stuff but it's so
funny because we're like so in each
other's [ __ ] always like walks in on me
yeah so that's great because that's like
busting that yeah me because i don't
want that that's like a shame thing
that's a thing where it's like i'm
supposed to be doing this like alone and
people aren't supposed to i don't think
for everyone but i'm saying for me
like yeah you know what i mean and it
was like this sort of because obviously
masturbation is like
i mean i think pretty great it is but
you know there's a lot of there are
still people online and wherever who are
like very anti-porn anti-masturbating
obviously i know bobby took it to the
point of extreme but i know for me like
in my life
we i i consider myself to be someone
that has a healthy sex life that also
includes like
doing it by yourself yeah when you want
to yeah and there's no judgment on that
because it's like sometimes that is what
you want to do totally and and i think
that
you know um
you know there's just
we gotta stop with thinking there's one
way to just be sexually healthy
you guys we talk about a lot of crazy
stuff today and that's why i'm so glad
our sponsors better help and we want you
to check out betterhelp betterhelp.com
trash tuesday it's not just help it's
better help this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp online therapy something we
all need something we think everyone
needs and we honestly can't shut up
about it can we no and you know what i
want to talk about today is burnout and
that is something that i get a lot of
help and therapy for and i think we're
all sort of collectively feeling it
right now like the world is picking back
up we're go go go go and i think a lot
of us are experiencing burnout and you
need help with that
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to and trust me that's a
good thing on my really difficult days i
don't want to be on video with anyone i
just want to sit in a dark corner and
talk to someone on the phone and that's
available to you depending on the
therapist i'm not sure if i want to see
them or not
i'm turning their camera off
it's much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours and you just
can save 1 000 on gas
also guys we just really want to remind
you that it's okay to prioritize
yourself yeah in fact it's a necessary
thing to prioritize yourself and you're
hearing that from three
co-host dependents
it's actually not okay to not prioritize
yeah you have to take yourself like i
feel like i learned that today just
listening and being a part of this
episode today no offense
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and trash tuesday listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday annie can you spell
uh that is b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash trash tuesday you guys
all the college babes out there summer's
around the corner listen the most
esther's gonna do is use a little
manscape in some areas it's not gonna be
a lot
we are very much okay with hair we just
need to feel like you care a little bit
about
you know our comfort and part of that is
just grooming and escaping yes
have you ever gone down on a guy and
then you just get kind of this like um
oh direction rash like around your yeah
on your face yes
oh or how about when you it looks like
you've been lying on a pillow because
their hair has
gotten in your skin
it's just
just be good to us okay just trim them
you are
wanting that from us we want it back i
use todd's todd sometimes will put an a
in there or he'll surprise me with some
shapes
shapes we love shapes be fun have fun i
mean we are a manscaped household we use
all their products todd wears the
underwear
we wear we use the
the body washes the ball washes all that
and their fourth generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce his grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 has a 7000 rpm motor i
don't know what it means but it sounds
fancy a new multi-function on and off
switch can engage a travel lock and
gives him the ability to turn on our
favorite feature the 400k led spotlight
on and off when needed for our more we
love the spotlight i can't do anything
without the spotlight personally and
when i'm manscaping my manscape for
christmas every man in my life got the
performance package 4.0 because they
have they don't just have the trimmer
they have the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer they have the crop
preservable deodorant the reviver toner
boxer briefs
their first shed travel bag even to hold
his goodies guys sorry go ahead i was
because i like the travel lock too
because you don't want i mean if you're
going through tsa and your thing is
buzzing they're not going to think
they're just gonna pull your dildo out
they're gonna pull it out thinking what
it is guys like like nice things that
are made for them too like you'd be
surprised there's men in your life that
would really appreciate this that maybe
wouldn't get it for themselves get 20
off let's free shipping with the code
trash at manscape.com that's 20 off plus
free shipping with the code trash at
manscape.com it's time for him to trim
off those spring flowers this summer at
give his beach balls a shine with
manscaped
to your point about feeling like we had
to hide our masturbation it's so funny
because like we were like like overly
sexualized as kids right and i feel the
same way like i and i sometimes i feel
like a fraud because i talk about sex so
openly with an audience with you guys
but when it comes to myself there's
those tiny moments where i feel like i
still have to like hide my pleasure
right or you know like we talked about
like hiding my face yeah because i might
i have to just like force myself to be
like there is nothing wrong here yeah
because it always reads as wrong like it
really it's really hard for me like in
sexual it just feels like really
bad yeah unless it's like
you know like the perfect scenario but
how often is it the perfect scenario no
one told us that we could enjoy it that
are that they cared about our enjoyment
is why it was their enjoyment their
pleasure was priority and ours was
secondary and that was most of our young
adults and now i have a partner who is
like the uh i mean i wouldn't say he's
the complete opposite like he obviously
enjoys his own pleasure but it's like he
is like i
derive pleasure from you having pleasure
from you feeling good from helping you
feel good making you feel good or
however and it's just like so weird
esther he is so awesome you look like
you've always just prioritized your
pleasure
i certainly have gone through versions
of things you guys are talking about of
course
i will say i would personally like to
outlaw the use of the word pocket [ __ ]
because it does
imply to me that like a [ __ ] is
something that is like an object that
you can grab and put in your pocket and
have like a fake version of which maybe
that's hers left her body yeah i imagine
her is like the
the um
the gateway uh remember the old
computers had the toaster oven
what should we call it a contraption
a construction
is it a sex toy is it a
what i don't know well what are what
dildos i guess are a completely new word
that's not like a severed dick yeah so
you're saying maybe we should also not
have penis veiny penis-shaped dildos you
can i don't know i've never also also
other misconception i've noticed is that
guys think vibrators are dildos like i
don't think guys know the difference
guys just think like all we want to use
carlos chime in no i just feel like i
know the difference but you were married
that's why
i feel like if you've been married yeah
i've gotten like a rabbit vibrator yeah
yeah but guys the rabbits are both the
rabbit
goes in and has the thing on top like it
doesn't have said
yeah she did put it in okay
guys don't know like like
i've never had a dildo i've only ever
had a vibrator right like i feel like
everyone i know is like that
i went through i had a dildo phase but
it was really yeah it was short-lived
i couldn't sustain it i think there was
one that like suctioned onto the wall i
was like there are things you can do but
i'm like is this
who is when there's no one else here i'm
like who is this boy how sad is it that
you have to like then pull it out and
then readjust because the height was
wrong
when you're like you're going up to the
mirror like
you're licking the end like all right
it falls off midway you're like what the
hell also i would like to picture you
saying who is this for and then calling
me
yours on facetime
oh
yeah my neighbors could hear it but
there i went through like a really kind
of fun masturbation time where i had
learned that you can you can like
manifest manifest well when you
masturbate what so i used to yes i used
to put money on this when i was broke oh
my god i spent money on my bed
and i would like put light candles give
myself like a whole experience have like
i have a like a silk
leopard print
um robe
and i would just like woo myself
but also like i would like say out loud
the things that i wanted while i was
coming and so i would say like netflix
or like whatever and then i was like i
should have said netflix special because
they probably just gave me like at 7.99
i used to scream like tesla when i would
come like my neighbors are wrong what
the hell is going on i like can't even
imagine using my brain to think about
other things while that's happening
that's impressive but anyhow i can't
imagine the opposite honestly i'm like
doing my taxes
okay gotta call my dad
um another thing that you know we were
talking about how we prepare our bodies
for doctor's appointments for tiny
things like that
i realize i prepare my body before i
masturbate i have to be showered
it's this weird [ __ ] thing i'm
telling you like i wish i could just
have even freedom with myself you don't
have morning sex with yourself
i don't i have to empty my bladder i
have to wash well that's good it's hard
to do i have to pee i can't really come
if i have to pee wash yeah i have to
wash i have to be like sort of like in
what i consider like pristine
condition and i'm like why do i do this
to myself why can't i just be a dirty
[ __ ] to myself
i do that with boyfriends sometimes too
where it's like i'm like oh i don't want
to like smell like todd's always like i
like how you smell like i like yeah and
i've had to have boyfriends really like
talk me into that because i have so much
like they're biologically geared to
wanting to want that smell and we're
washing off that smell and it's like i
like smell like their balls for two
hours afterwards me too
like literally like they dabbed their
balls spicy bulk and you know how like
[ __ ] sort of smells like chlorine it
tastes like
like bleach
it's like
wow that's a very good come you're
swallowing because some of the stuff
that i've gotten down my throat is not
bleachy well it's a competing
brand but i want to talk about it so bad
todd takes hymns and it makes his semen
thinner
hair thicker semen thinner is one of the
things which is so funny like look at
this skinny jizz
i it's so interesting you you want to be
so clean because i feel like the most
like excited i get is literally when i
feel so filthy like if i just had like
well you would never you would never
have sex if that wasn't the case yeah
that's true
i told you this esther i really do want
to get to that level of like
[ __ ] it it's just let's be animals
all right we have to have stinky [ __ ]
no no like let's all i'm gonna try to
stinky [ __ ] masturbate first before i
move on to the sex okay because i wasn't
like eat a cheeseburger feel gross do i
shove the cheeseburger up no no but it's
just like the way the cheeseburger makes
you feel you're just like oh i'm trash
like might as well [ __ ] i think my
problem though is like inspect my brain
because i because i have dark feelings
towards sex my brain is trying to like
disassociate and get to other places so
i feel like if i'm full that might not
help
i'll be like oh you know like it's like
my brain's looking for excuses to not
also it's like for me
the the fear of possibly farting so loud
when i come it's just like a fear that
like keeps me up has it ever happened it
has
it's a fear that wakes todd up in the
morning
yeah because everything sort of like
tightens right
in front of bobby i don't fart in front
of them you don't i finally did last
week boyfriends you can fart for i have
probably farted onto his face
into his mouth directly just really
incredibly nonsense i'm so glad you guys
are filling in that spot for me because
then then i feel like okay he has no
short shortage of farts in his face but
i i farted for the first time in front
of him because we're working on things
in front of him
so you're like in the therapy and
they're like squeeze it out kalila
squeeze it off that's what i did that's
exactly what happened and i ended up
sharting because
because
we we had you know we were in the cat we
were on the couch and he was like come
on like it'll make me feel so much
closer to you so i was like okay okay
let me just you know brew one for you on
the spot but it took about 10 minutes
and he had walked away
i can't brew one oh you
can
you can hebrew one
so um so he walks away and then finally
i had brewed one and there was you know
there was one in the chamber
so i called i was like bobby there's one
there's one you gotta come hurry before
it goes away so he sprints over to the
room and like with all my might i push
what i think is a fart but it was only
half far to half [ __ ] and immediately he
was like babe you gotta go check that
immediately he was like i never want to
hear you do that again
he was so turned off it backfired he was
like pleased for the love of god never
do that in fact i heard it front fired
i love that he's the expert on sharding
he's like i i from what i heard i know
you need to go to the bathroom exactly
and you know what he was not wrong he
was not wrong
which one of your which one of your
foster dogs lick that [ __ ] off girl
funny you ask funny ass
you know what thank you for asking
because the truth is i call all of my
dogs over if there's an especially dirty
panty to be had
esther don't even lie i know you do the
same i don't call her over but she finds
me
it is funny sometimes i'm like why today
of all days but she goes to town maybe
she knows when you're ovulating yeah
because they do this thing where it's
actually really cute where they like
they roll over it like it's a dead
carcass they put it on there oh they're
so happy they're happy and is that what
boys want to do too
are boys just holding back is that what
they're like interested in since you're
straight
wait you're straight today this episode
you're straight so do you want to like
it's as straight as that roll around on
a dirty underwear i feel like yeah like
any sort of musky like thing is like a
turn-on so whether it's like the breath
or panties or whatever
it's a turn-on
i like that you're a real carlos this is
such a relief you get to eat my [ __ ]
once a week
while i watch
that should be the next my first stinky
[ __ ] sex is going to be with carlos
i have an idea the next live is
bobby has to figure out whose breath has
your [ __ ] on it
wait or he has to smell her [ __ ] and
just guess who ate it out
here
oh my god okay so holy week just passed
okay what is that um as a catholic i'm
here to tell you that for us it was
great growing up because we had the
whole week off from school it's like a
federal
holidays yeah for us so everyone goes to
the beach and believe it or not
the week holy week is the week
that's for you [ __ ]
you get high [ __ ] that's it annie
you're not wrong because everyone gets
as [ __ ] up as possible we go to the
beach towns or we go to places like
boracay and everyone gets shit-faced for
holy week oh that's fun that was a
tradition in the philippines in the
philippines over here you guys are kind
of like really stiff catholic all i know
about holy week is that i'm not allowed
to talk to my shaman for seven days and
it is not good why because he's doing
he's
oh he's he's rising too he's doing this
he's he's feeling the the jesus vibes
on sunday on um he text him and you're
like have you risen i'm back i'm back
hello yeah i can't imagine someone
telling you seven days no talking like
it's hard i don't know what that brings
out of you but it can't be good they
have those retreats you know what it
does it makes me handle my own [ __ ] and
it's so sad that i need it like the
other day i was having this like
meltdown and i went to san francisco and
i had by the way an incredible time i
mean san francisco is our people i mean
it's our people
i came and i was like san francisco
filled with the two things i love the
most crabs and asian people
i'm so happy like see what in asian
people but it was like so fun the shows
were like just it was just so fun but
the first night
i just started talking [ __ ] and could
not stop talking [ __ ] like and because i
talk so much [ __ ] on other people
it came back to me so hard later that
night like i went back to my hotel room
todd came the next day but it was just
me josh had gone
to bed i don't know with who but josh
was away having fun i was like alone i
was alone in my hotel room and i
started watching my sets from the week
before at the comedy store and i was
high as [ __ ]
and i every mean thing i said about
anyone else
came stabbing me in the face like i was
like i'm the worst comedian i can't
believe this like i just started feeling
so insecure it was too late to call
anyone i couldn't like soothe with
anyone else i had to just like deal with
it cry feel horrible good for you and
then the next day i'm like trying to
call my hypnotist bonnie mcfarlane had
um
covid i was like
like my soothers my people i call we're
gone it's holy week i can't talk to my
[ __ ] like i was like
but i just had to get through it and
then realize that it was
a weird moment of just like allowing
other people's like i don't know i just
like i just decided to like well you
know that's like a common thing of like
if you're
saying something about someone else
it that's like a
it's a it's a scary thought when you
realize it but a lot of people say that
that means that's what you your
insecurity about yourself is like a
mirror yeah
i don't know if that's true because i
was talking some very specific [ __ ] i
was really getting to that
no but it was just like but what to what
you're saying like i do think it's like
you open up that channel exactly and
then and i think that it was like
important for me to kind of like beat
myself that way because
why should i be able to just like throw
it out and then not also feel that way
speaking of self-flagellation
yes the flogging
um our little foggy girl yeah so i
remember of um during holy week this is
why i always say the catholics are so
tame here like what do what do catholics
do here they go to church
and like how do people celebrate you get
school off on friday and monday just
good friday that's it
that's it yeah i'm pretty sure that's
what it was my uncle carlo every what so
close it was so close
my uncle carla it would be a fun thing
for our family to watch him get
crucified oh yeah they had stations
so like effort for for easter my family
would go to the province and then my
aung we would watch our uncle be
crucified
and that was a fun
yeah because we have to reenact the
crucifixion of jesus was he holding on
to the thing no no no no he gets nailed
every year do people look it up look
it's it's look it up right now
look it up it's a big thing in the
philippines people get crucified every
year you have what if carlos couldn't
type because there was so much blood
coming out of his hands because he had
done it this week reenactment he really
is uncle carlo
[Laughter]
this next sponsor makes me smile and
feel happy because obviously it's magic
spoon and i love
being a kid yes
childlike behavior is
to my right over smiley smiley
um you guys we're all trying to eat
better and healthy breakfast doesn't
have to be boring by the way i eat magic
spoon for dinner the magic spoon has the
amazing flavors you love but without all
the bad stuff and it's amazing as a
midnight snack right before bed right
after you're set at the comedy store or
if you have gerd you gotta wait you
gotta just
if you eat it you gotta wait a couple
hours before you go to bed it's zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
which is i think
essentially what was missing in all of
our cereal because back in the day just
to be just all carbs and sugar right but
now with magic spoon you're actually
getting some protein we just got a new
box i'm so excited i know when i run out
i'm so sad what i like to do is i have
it on hand at home and then like when
i'm hungry but i'm kind of craving
something sweet i'll be like that's my
dinner tonight because it makes me feel
full and it's satisfying and it's
actually good for me okay you guys it's
keto friendly gluten-free grain-free soy
free and even low-carb go to
magicspoon.com
tuesday to grab a custom bundle of
cereal today and be sure to use our
promo code tuesday at checkout to save
five dollars off your order also what
are you gonna say no to cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies and cream
maple waffle blueberry cinnamon and plus
the newly reformulated honey nut flavor
come on guys and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
i also the fact that you just listed the
flavors is making me so hungry and i
really want people if you're magic spoon
people comment what flavor you like
because i'm team fruity and mix them mix
them up team fruity remember get you
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode but what is
all our favorite flavors oh i'm i'm a
frosty for life i do peanut butter and
cookies and cream together fruity
see every year
reenactment of jesus christ and it was
always your uncle was it because he had
the scar tissue um my uncle was he ended
up being a murderer and he actually got
out of prison yeah your uncle yeah and i
i look back now i'm like well of course
see these guys this is this is very tame
back in the day they actually used to
just have volunteers really go through
the pain of crucifixion
see look they have a nail through his
hands do you see it brian
so you have the nail through his hand
like that but they didn't give the
straps to jesus did they they didn't
make him suffer ours was just like a
mexican guy holding wood like like
oh my god who's wood
so this is my uncle carlo
this is not really him oh my god i was
like oh my goodness you guys i didn't
like religion before this and now
gangster i like the girl with the dreads
watching really young the tourist is
just hanging chilling smoking some weed
but then
some women too they they do the flogging
so they do the flagellation
i literally feel like i'm going to pass
out this is so disturbing but he's happy
to be doing that because he's feeling
the pain that jesus so he's he's jesus
in this moment he's a star that's sad
he's hurting himself you should never
walk in on me masturbating by the way if
you think that's bad
[Laughter]
i really want to know you're wrong i
actually have walked
i really want to know everyone's oh face
i don't think i even have anything
exciting for you either
i'm very standard as bobby would say he
always says you have standard [ __ ] and
standard
that's gonna hurt it does he said it on
the live he was like
he just had a standard [ __ ] he said my
my smell was very standard i'm just
telling you after having dated a guy who
said who
said i have hyper-sensitive smell i i'm
telling you it's better for someone to
say that then for them to just dangle in
front of you that they can smell
everything that you think they can't
smell also how [ __ ] up is it that i
would to be called standard smelling
would be the highest compliment i think
i could ever get because you were born
so weird you're just you're just chasing
basically you can't yes
yes
wait back to something you said about
like the shaman having holy week and
having to be quiet for a week i
learned something about myself that
it's just a lesson like
i had a friend who
i would always talk to all the time and
all this person would do was complain
and
i realized well they're just using me to
complain like this is so [ __ ] up but
then low-key i'm like what am i getting
out of this why am i doing this and i
learned oh this is how i'm escaping from
my problems is taking on this other
person's problems
and it sounds easier to do that and i'm
like i've wasted so much of my life
doing that and it really pisses me off
so i just kind of wanted to share i
don't know yeah no we get these like
little armies of people that were like
for or
they're with you know they're with us
we're with them and then you're just
like wait i'm not i it's like i don't
think i said it
uh on camera but when i was doing
ayahuasca and i turned my phone on too
early i wasn't supposed to have my phone
on and kalyla right at that moment was
like did you see kate quigley overdose i
was like it was literally like the worst
moment these three people in our in our
field overdosed three died one survived
and i'm like
i was still like tripping and i had to i
had to consciously go like kate i am
like sending all the love and light in
the world but you cannot be my journey
because i so easily i already had to
push off a guy sitting next to me in my
ayahuasca journey was like when we were
just sharing our intentions and stuff he
was like before we did it he went you
know the mother of my children just
passed away and so i've just been
dealing with that and i literally had
never met this man before and in my
ayahuasca journey i had to be like
dead wife you've got to go it's not
about you but annie feeling his pain for
him if there was ever ever a symptom of
codependency it's that is that we're
taking on other things that we should
just know
will show it to you right away like and
i had one one journey where i really
went
like because when i do these weekends
it's there's two nights that you do
ayahuasca and so one of the nights i did
my whole journey was i was feeling so
much guilt because i've been talking
[ __ ] on people and so then i had to feel
the things their their side of all of
our arguments and that was good for me
to feel that right like to feel the
other side like oh yes people are
victims of me as much as i'm assuming
i'm victims of them you know do i come
up in your journey is that you've i've
never thought of you but i'm not with
you carlos i don't even remember you
exist
but not the best insult
i think though i said that to rama yusuf
once he was like do you think of me and
i went i really honestly do not think of
you unless you're in front of my face
this is a good time for me to tell
everybody that today is carlos's
birthday and now i acknowledge happy
birthday but i actually i don't even
believe that like it doesn't hurt it
doesn't you don't believe it's your
birthday that's so good you're learning
carlos no i believe that i'm higher up
than rami yusuf in your brain in reality
you are you guys i can't believe i'm
going to say this as it was a bit i was
working on but i never quite figured it
out but i really wanted to do a bit
about how like you know everyone says
women aren't funny but i think we need
to focus on on the men in the world who
are not funny to just like rebrand
comedy is that why you hang out with
carlos
but like that is so mean
though that's your birthday present no
that means we're doing banana break
right now okay banana bread
[Music]
you know carlos i have a
observation about i'm gonna call it an
observation it was really an initial
complaint but um these bananas are very
green but soft on the edges so i know
someone has slammed them down to the
ground i don't know who is that a part
of your birthday celebration slamming
bananas i would never prank the bananas
for you girl who slammed my bananas
carlos what are you doing to these
bananas it's the air one employee he was
in a bad mood probably when
it's actually iron which you would know
for the bananas and i do appreciate that
yeah we actually on a serious note we
really appreciate that yeah it's an
extremely easy bait i'm so happy that we
get to give you a job on your birthday
[Laughter]
the one place to be looking for for so
long
no actually i don't need a job this is
definitely charity to you i know so rich
um i wanted to ask you since you're our
um
broadway connoisseur
yes
i just saw that pam anderson plays
rocky heart in chicago on broadway i
know i'm going this weekend and i'm like
i should probably i think i might get
tickets i've been researching the
reviews she can't even breathe she's
talking something
like i can't even believe it's happening
i love that role i love her um people
are saying she's giving a good
performance which i the way they're
saying it i feel like is sort of to say
like she's giving it yeah
so i'm gonna try to get a ticket though
for saturday because this is such a big
deal like i literally can't believe it's
happening it's just so funny that if she
called me a broadway connoisseur i would
be insulted
i'm like ruling on myself
and you're going to wait when where is
she doing this here or there you're
going to new york in new york yeah yeah
like is there anyone is there any star
that if they were on broadway you guys
would go like pay whatever it costs
myself
good answer
honestly my answer is you as well
yeah are we doing a play yeah by the way
how much better does our name fit now
why
because we talked [ __ ] now it's fun oh
i know whenever trisha paytas mentions
our podcast she always calls it trash
talk it's perfect
i like that people kind of like [ __ ] it
up yeah it's funny
trash tuesdays it's trash tuesday people
call it a lot because of the instagram
okay and i did notice this are those
[ __ ] skins soft they're skim socks
and kanye shoes i feel guilty
don't to put them together iconic combo
the kids are
that's good for the kids this is for
north carolina yeah
yes
who can come at the same time isn't it
oh you know what when a guy comes it
makes me want to come
it kind of turns me on there's something
about the kind of like uh because in
that moment i know nothing is going on
in their brain there's not a thought
behind those eyes and for some reason
it's just all physical and it turns me
on in fact when i'm masturbating
watching a guy come makes me come you
should um you should watch a guy listen
to me talk for the third hour why todd
has nothing behind his eyes
todd has like the perfect amount of i
don't care when he's like there's
certain times where i'm like i know
you're not listening
he just kind of smiles
i'm taught on the third hour he's just
like
we've been hearing this story quite a
bit he'll hear me do the rounds do i
call everyone tell them the same story
like to i don't even think there are
words for me to describe to you how much
i literally i mean i'm in love with todd
when i see him i feel something so good
he is so wise because when we're face
timing he's always in the background and
he's listening but like passively right
but then he chimes in once in a while
and he says one just really profound
thing where i'm like oh my god todd
you're right yes and like if we're
dealing with a problem and he has this
solution all of a sudden he comes in
with it and you're like [ __ ] todd you're
right yep that's that has to be so
frustrating that he and within one
sentence he always has a solution but
has to sit through three hours of you
but here's the [ __ ] up thing he likes
me yeah he likes it
there's no
like i feel no like talky shame which
i've definitely felt with guys and trust
me if you're dating me and you're
annoyed with me talking my
gut cannot do anything but talk more
faster louder
i think that is the sweetest thing like
of all the things that i know to be true
about bobby and i is that we genuinely
like each other yes like you can throw
us in any different lifetime dimension
[ __ ] multiverse
we will always sit across from each
other and say i really really like you i
like everything about you and i think
that's that's um you know we've had a
very
um
complicated
last couple years but when when i'm on
the phone with him when we're facetiming
and it's just him and i talking i
[ __ ] like him so much you know what
you can get to 10 years without that you
really can't it's like i noticed that
too like
dave and i we have our [ __ ] and he
annoys me and i certainly annoy him but
i'm always like
whenever we sit and talk like i like you
i really like talking to you i know it's
fun to have the partner that you go to
because i i don't know if it's mutual
but that's so funny he's on a podcast
saying the exact opposite right now
[Music]
um yeah no it's really it's really cool
he says the right things he also he just
knows me really well he's also a very
good judge of character and i
don't fully accept that yet but it's it
always in retrospect he goes i [ __ ]
told you like he knows like there'll be
people he's like that's not someone you
should be talking to like come on but
they're at the coffee shop all the time
he also does this thing where
when i'm in any sort of mood that's not
the ideal mood he has the right song for
me oh yeah so he has like songs that he
plays he's your personal dj he's the
best he's the personal soundtrack guy
you know what i found out about myself
two weeks ago after i read an article
was
i'm a crybaby girl do you know what a
crybaby girl is no um we're easy criers
it's exactly what it is like there's
just a subset of us that cry to
everything and that's me
that's definitely
good bad in between i cry yeah to the
death i i mean i cry a lot but it's like
i want to be crying a lot more and then
like this is me but when i was a kid i
would catch that
did anyone have this as a kid
um
i
was so scared of being like vulnerable
and emotional in front of my family that
i would
like if something like if someone were
watching anna green gable sorry spoiler
alert
matthew the the f the grandfather or the
uncle that's watching her or if it's her
grandfather
he dies in one of the episodes and i
just remember going it's just an actor
and i'm like four years old it's like
weird to know this but just trying to
like disassociate from any of the
feelings and then my mom would be crying
and i'd be like really you're crying
it's just an actor mom like judging the
but at four is like a weird thing that
is happening
did you try to land before time
i would cry to them but i'd be like
choking i didn't want people to see my
like emotions i don't want people to see
me like lamb before time is a triggering
subject for me because when i was little
all my friends
and then one day after that that movie
came out the same time jurassic park
came out and all my friends at school
saw that and i my appearance because i
was
watched not raised i was just a tag
along they took me to see jurassic park
and i was so [ __ ] so you were a skin
tag
esther teratoma
i was so traumatized and scared and so
jealous that all the kids got to see
like the fun movie anyways and then you
never watched a movie again yeah
but why would someone at four be
thinking that way that's what i'm
curious
probably
happened in a closet with uncle jack
wasn't my own we should never don't call
people that aren't their uncle uncle
they're gonna molest them i had a
revelation in the last two weeks that i
was really afraid to say out loud before
and i think that my resistance to having
children for so long is because i've had
this feeling this overwhelming feeling
and thought that i've always wanted to
kill my bloodline
that i looked at my uncles and my family
members and saw just really shitty
people growing up that i thought i
i had carried this feeling of not
wanting to perpetuate
or spread seeds or i wanted to be the
last person like in line granted they're
all having kids the bloodline has been
perpetuated yeah but if if we if now we
gotta go kill them
yeah
and that's impossible our horror movie
starts but yeah that's and it was a
really sad thing for me to like say out
loud to myself and then say out loud to
somebody else yeah it was just like what
has been holding me back because i do
feel some type of like maternal feeling
of wanting to like raise children and i
do get those oh like i watch the show
called old enough and i cry just the
whole time i'm just crying crying crying
because i see little kids do their first
errands and it's so cute and so sweet
but then
opposite side of that i'm just like i
cannot i cannot like it's gonna come out
bad my my genetics are bad there's
mental illness like just they're shitty
people we have shitty people in my
family and this this competing thoughts
in my head that just cannot come up like
every day it's been such a [ __ ]
like mind [ __ ] for me because i have
those two competing things do you think
every day do you think it's like comes
down to like a self-worth thing
maybe because it's like if you really
are like loving yourself you know that
whatever child you have is gonna be so
loved and so taken care of like you
would never
never going to repeat those
patterns it's striking me as like so
much overthinking it is looking at me as
someone who literally was pregnant for
three months thought they were gonna
have a kid i nev none of no thoughts
like that ever crossed my mind i'm i'm
like i just was like i'll figure it out
like it'll be fine i didn't i used to
say i didn't want to have kids
i used to be like i don't have kids and
it was because i was so still so angry
and still so like
stuff was so not well inside me still
like i was like i was really afraid that
i wasn't gonna be able to do it
and the more i've worked on myself the
more i'm like i like
i can't wait to like teach my kids
things that i learned i can't wait i've
learned so much from my parents like and
in the forgiving of them and like how
our relationship has developed since
then and it's like there's no way i'm
making those same mistakes like i'm sure
there's going to be things that i can't
even blind spots that i have no clue
that are going to come out but and i
think like the right partner is really
like todd's not going to let me do
anything to those kids
todd's not going to let me
make those maybe that is what i'm
counting on yeah it's going to handle it
todd's not going to let my kids
todd just moves in with you i'm like
todd can you come over to my house
i'll let you guys in on a secret
um that
which is why you know
it i guess a
caution to everybody that sometimes what
you hear in a podcast is more often
times ingest especially like for a show
like tiger belly where you know the
narrative has always been that bobby
wants a child and that i'm the one who
has not wanted a child and while those
two competing thoughts of wanting to
kill my bloodline and feeling maternal
compete every day it was about three
years ago when i finally told bobby
that i was ready to have children and it
was exactly three years ago that his
porn addiction became really really bad
but then what used to hurt me a lot was
getting messages saying you're not
giving bobby a child when i had already
agreed to it and i was excited about it
right and then the sex just stopped and
immediately i felt like
oh my god like
like let me just go jump off a cliff
then finally
finally feeling like this was such a big
decision for me to make because i'm like
i'm so afraid i'm so afraid but oh okay
let's do it you know and then to be
basically rejected and then i felt like
just rejected like there were moments
where i was just like
can we please like have sex like
can we like do we have nothing to do
right now
and it would just not get there and i
would feel like
i just
yeah i'm going to quit cocaine like what
am i and it's like also when you're
sexualized young so much of your worth
is in your sexuality too and like so but
that constant narrative of the pressure
of like people saying like you're a
selfish [ __ ] for not wanting to have
kids and like guys the truth is like
like you don't know what's going on in
our relationship and truly like
i i have said yes to have it to finally
like yes
i did dmt with one of my ex-boyfriends
once and i was like
had just catapulted through this like
kaleidoscope of like first of all you
smoke it out of a crack pipe so you're
really leaning in
it's like it's like literally like one
of those glass things with like the ball
at the end and you cook it so it's a
weird thing but it's a beautiful drug
how long does it last um like five to
ten minutes oh that's it yeah it's
really short but sometimes people think
they're there forever i mean you guys
would
love it but you really would love it but
it's crack no no no it's
dmt dude
i'm like you do crack
you're like how do i do it that's next
and my hand is out
[Laughter]
um but anyway so yeah so i like when i
came out i realized like the message i
kept getting was like i'm supposed to be
a mother
and i had been really really denying
that part of myself and really afraid to
even like entertain it and so i came out
and i just was still kind of [ __ ] up
and i was like
yeah you know like i think i'm supposed
to be a mother and he started [ __ ]
screaming at me and was like i knew you
wanted a [ __ ] kid you were lying to
me
all this stuff and i was like first of
all we didn't even talk about it who was
this
who do you think would you scream it
wake me up in the middle of screaming
but it was like so crazy and then i was
like
that i didn't say with you psycho
because i couldn't have kids with him he
would have they would have died they
wouldn't have made it no they would not
have made it i really what i really hope
for you kalila is
maybe you didn't feel it then but at
least now i hope that you know
not to take that personally what
happened because it's so obvious that
that was bobby's issues yeah it it
wasn't him speaking to me his addiction
was yes okay and you know that yeah but
even if it was him speaking it's all his
stuff on you it's not a rejection of you
it's like so obvious that it was
something that he was like yeah and the
minute it got real it's like he's afraid
the way that you're afraid of what
you're going to bring into the world he
must be dealing with something very
similar right and i think the problem in
our relationship then was that we're
very ambivalent right like we're just
two people that just get along so it's
like all the hard stuff we're kind of
just like
all right we'll still continue to be
together we're not really facing it head
on so what we're doing now is really
learning to be uncomfortable with these
like really
tough conversations before we would just
be like all right cool wanna watch
american idol you know what i mean well
that's literally like the definition of
human nature it's like if you're if you
can find comfort you just go to it and
you stick with it no one naturally wants
to like have a hard conversation or like
take a big scary step it is something
that you have to really be conscious of
and put effort into there's definitely a
psycho out there that likes it there's
definitely someone that's like ready for
the confrontation
us right now
no but um dr drew said this to me i keep
thinking of things dr drew said to me
this magical man um but he was like he
said to me that he thinks i have a
problem with grieving and maybe you have
some of that too
like facing things or whatever like
because what you just don't know
what you have what you just shared with
us to us did not like land sad it didn't
like i can feel for you i can understand
what you're going through and i can like
understand you better now but i didn't
take that as like you told me a bad
thing or anything right that it was dark
or anything it's like really real and
it's like helpful to people to hear
people just thank you and you know if
there's anything we learned today is
that your [ __ ] can't perish and mine
perished
[Music]
and we're gonna find out what she
manifests with that vagina and then i
can tell you the rest of the egg stuff
tomorrow you guys thank you for
listening this episode i hope was as
therapeutic for you as it was for me and
for these old sperms um please subscribe
to this channel and thank you to
everyone who came to the live stream it
was so much fun and we really want to
see you guys at the next one if you
missed it we're going to have a lot more
interaction we're already planning the
next one we're very excited and what
else
comment and let us know what you thought
comment i'm not reading them anymore i'm
making bets with todd now where it's
like i have to do things like to buy
them a lobster and i can't eat any of it
it's not we haven't quite gotten the
punishment right that's fun i love that
[ __ ] yeah we'll see you guys next time
bye thanks guys
you